on continue à parler nature avec trois
invités qui viennent d'arriver Frédéric
Antoine co-fondateur de la marche de la
bière Francis tac photographe à Buc et
aussi Véronique Ferret directrice de
l'office de tourisme de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ce qui vous
lit tous les trois c'est la bière
Véronique Ferret vous êtes là pour nous
parler de l'exposition que vous proposez
depuis le début de la semaine la Bièvre
rivière vivante qui se tient jusqu'à
samedi 1er juin pourquoi cette
exposition
alors je m'appelle Valérie pardon
Valérie
pourquoi cette exposition parce que la
BIAF fait partie du patrimoine de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et que on est
fier de pouvoir la partager avec les
gens qui habitent le territoire et
au-delà et puis le fait que la marge de
la Bièvre se finit à 50 ans en Yvelines
à Guyancourt précisément cette année
nous a incités effectivement à faire un
peu un zoom sur sur ce patrimoine donc
voilà on en parlera tout à l'heure de la
marche quelle est l'histoire de la
rivière en quelques dates clés
alors elle est elle existe depuis une
fort longtemps date clé je dirais
1400 50 à peu près avec gobelins les
teinturies et puis après Louis XIV avec
l'aménagement de la minière justement
pour amener les eaux au château de
Versailles et puis petit à petit elle a
enfin notamment à Guyancourt elle a
continué son histoire avec aussi un
aménagement pour la baignade dans les
années 60-70 elle a été aussi beaucoup
polluée alors au-delà après au-delà de
Saint-Quentin au-delà de la haute vallée
elle a été polluée par les métiers de
tanneur notamment et puis en arrivant
sur Paris elle a même fini son histoire
dans les égouts parce qu'avant elle se
jetait dans la scène mais elle a été
détournée petit à petit
de Paris on sait pas encore précisément
alors elle est couverte donc c'est c'est
un peu compliqué mais peut-être que
Frédéric Antoine peut m'aider sur cet
aspect là
oui la Bièvre a été couverte il faut
préciser
toute la partie finalement
après Anthony
est complètement fermé et invisible
néanmoins il y a quand même des
réouverture qui se sont faites de
manière successives et à certains
endroits on peut redécouvrir la bière et
dans Paris finalement ce n'est plus les
eaux de la Bièvre qui passent puisqu'
avant-paris et les détournée sur
d'autres destinations merci pour ces
précisions dans l'exposition on découvre
aussi les fameux métiers qui étaient
développés autour de la Bièvre notamment
la blanchisserie où ils la vont dire les
lavandières effectivement en raison de
la qualité très pure de l'eau non
calcaire
effectivement il y avait des métiers de
lavandière sur les sur les rives de la
rivière et puis les tanneurs donc
c'était vraiment très emblématique j'ai
oublié de citer Oberkampf bien sûr donc
mais à travers l'exposition justement le
but de cette expo c'est vraiment de se
rendre compte de son histoire de son
environnement de sa faune et puis une
incitation à la balade au travers les
photos de justement de Francis tac tout
à fait on devient justement on peut
admirer vos photos Francis tac vous êtes
le photographe officiel de cette
exposition si on peut dire on y trouve
des cartes postales d'archives en noir
et blanc et aussi des images couleurs
qui sont les vôtres à quelle période
avez-vous pris ces clichés
j'ai commencé à travailler sur la Bièvre
dans les années 80 puisque ça fait
l'objet dans les années 90 d'un premier
livre qui a été édité avec Jacques de
Givry qui s'appelle la bière
voilà un des livres que vous avez édité
donc ça c'est la haute vallée de la
Bièvre puisque ça va de Guyancourt
jusqu'à Igny et une dizaine d'années
plus tard on a sorti la Bièvre
redécouverte alors c'est justement pour
évoquer ce dont on parlait à deux
minutes à savoir le parcours de la
Bièvre jusqu'à Paris au pont
d'Austerlitz et puis à travers son
parcours aujourd'hui en terrain dans les
communes de d'Arcueil cachant Gentilly
13e arrondissement à Paris puis le
Jardin des Plantes et elle se jetait en
fait au niveau du pont d'Austerlitz donc
même s'il y a une volonté politique
aujourd'hui de remettre en eau les
rivières dans les grandes villes bon
c'est un sujet passionnant mais bon ce
qui m'a ce qui m'a plu depuis que
j'habite la région depuis les années 80
c'est donc la beauté de cette vallée qui
a travers Guyancourt
buts
donc je suis entre Jouy-en-Josas et puis
Guyancourt et je cours régulièrement je
fais de l'exercice physique autour des
autour des étangs de Guyancourt et c'est
vraiment le coeur de la bière c'est un
des plus beaux endroits je pense de la
région parisienne et qu'est-ce qui est
temps pour vous pardon qu'est-ce qui est
important pour vous dans la photographie
parce que c'est la lumière je suis un je
suis un photographe de la lumière et de
la couleur et
je pense que les gens qui me connaissent
ont même fait la réputation
ma réputation vis-à-vis de la couleur
rouge je les ai sorti même un livre qui
s'appelle rouge désert
pour montrer la couleur rouge à travers
non seulement
les couleurs des paysages mais les
couleurs des gens qui vivent au désert
en l'occurrence sur la bière moi je suis
pas certain d'avoir trouvé beaucoup de
rouge mais on va dire que c'était la
ville la ville et la vallée vertébrés
qui défilent sur l'écran en fait on a je
suis aussi l'auteur
de ce livre qui était sorti il y a
presque une vingtaine d'années sur 50
ans
donc la naissance de la Bièvre à
Guyancourt et cette c'est très beau
étangs qui figure vous êtes aussi un
photographe de paysages et de l'humain
il y a quelques activités aujourd'hui
encore autour de la Bièvre il y a
beaucoup de choses il y a notamment pas
mal de courses et puis entre autres il y
a que ça à deux semaines les cauterelles
de Paris qui est parti de Saint-Quentin
pour rejoindre la Tour Eiffel donc des
gens qui font 80 km à pied qui qui
parcourent les étangs de la bière à
force de vie enfin à vive allure non il
y a toujours une activité importante une
activité physique on voit à l'exposition
à l'Office de Tourisme qui a ça c'était
avec les conditions difficiles de
l'hiver mais ce qu'on voit c'est qu'il y
a une une quarantaine d'années
maintenant on pouvait se baigner dans la
Bièvre il y avait la plage ça j'ai pas
connu
d'accord alors sur les murs on peut
aussi voir des petits poèmes c'est un
partenariat avec la maison de la poésie
Valérie Ferrer juste en quelques mots
la Maison de la Poésie s'est associée à
nous pour le montage de cette expo et
pour promouvoir la marge de la bière
puisque le la fin du parcours va être
jalonné de poèmes effectivement il y a
de très très beaux poèmes et Chris sur
la bière
de Ronsard à Victor Hugo on a essayé de
prendre des extraits pour inciter
justement à la au rêve à la poésie
puisque vous parlez de Victor Hugo moi
j'ai eu un petit coup de coeur pour une
citation si je peux me permettre je la
lis là des sauts le pensif qui pleure
sur la rive et comme une baigneuse
indolente et naïve laisse tremper dans
l'eau le bout de leurs cheveux Victor
Hugo alors ces poèmes vont jalonner
aussi on l'a dit le parcours enfin les
parcours de la marche de la Bièvre
Frédéric Antoine vous êtes le
co-fondateur de cet événement
c'est quelle est la particularité des
parcours
effectivement la marge de la Bièvre
maintenant à 31 ans
cette marche c'est trois parcours un
parcours qu'on appelle la marche à la
lune puisqu'il part à minuit de
la du parvis de Notre-Dame pour
rejoindre Guyancourt à Paris
effectivement un deuxième parcours qui
est la marche à l'aurore et là on
découvre la vallée sous un autre
un autre une autre aspect c'est-à-dire
au lever du soleil à partir de 4h30 du
matin à
Igny avec un départ et une arrivée à
Guyancourt et puis une troisième marche
qui fait la marche au soleil
effectivement qui elle part également
Dini et arrive à Guyancourt sur un
parcours de 19 km faut quand même mettre
un peu initié alors sur 19 km ça reste
tout à fait faisable et on marche à 4
km/h on est plus dans le cadre de la
promenade sur la marche à l'horreur fait
28 km on va dire c'est une promenade un
peu soutenue avec une volonté d'arrivée
et sur 50 km c'est quand même pour les
initiés et les gens qui aiment marcher
et qui ont l'habitude de marcher des
longues distances est-ce que les
inscriptions sont encore possibles alors
tout à fait les inscriptions sont encore
possibles jusqu'à samedi soir minuit le
20 avril le 20 avril non jusqu'à samedi
soir minuit sur le site internet ce
samedi soir
sur le site internet marche de la
biaf.org et dans lequel il y a toutes
les informations inscriptions
effectivement par internet et puis si
par hasard il vous n'avez pas pu vous
inscrire sur le site internet vous
pouvez venir sur place et vous inscrire
une demi-heure avant le départ on va
dire pour la marge de nuit il faut mieux
arriver une petite heure avant le départ
à l'avance et vous pourrez vous inscrire
sur place et participer l'ensemble du du
parcours bien sûr est sécurisé balisé et
il y a des ravitaillements tout le temps
alors rendez-vous est pris pour les
sportifs dimanche 21 avril je rappelle
que l'exposition la Bièvre rivière
vivante se tient elle jusqu'au 1er juin
à l'office de tourisme de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines merci à tous
les trois d'être venu sur notre plateau